okay am I talking to the leads of a Star
Wars show right now welcome back to
reality
Star Wars is so shrouded in secrecy so
when did you find out who did you tell
and what was your reaction let's walk
through the whole process okay fine I
found out when I was just walking to my
car one morning at my agent called and
her words were do not tell a soul so so
you can't again no but you can't tell
anyone you know but it's fun
because yeah well for me when I found
out that I had booked because it is I
own on Star Wars resistance I was
ecstatic I was over the moon I couldn't
believe it I remember thinking this is
amazing and how long until we can tell
someone so after I posted on Instagram
no I'm kidding no I know yeah it was one
of those things where I was like how do
you keep this a secret you know you're
like you're working on a new project
sure you're working on a project you get
a lot of those but at the same time it's
like you'll see you'll see what was the
first Star Wars movie that you saw on
what was your biggest memory of it star
wars movie that I saw it was a little
older but it came out the year I was
born um and it was the return of the
Jedi Empire Strikes Back it's still my
favorite and most quoted movie I
remember just kind of seeing it with my
dad and do or do not there is no try
like that is the same we still live by
you know our household you don't say you
can't do it you know yeah I really do I
know you might want to say your own
character but who is your favorite Star
Wars character in life I'd say for me
it's Jabba the Hutt no getting enough
you know are we talking two whole Star
Wars oh yeah Luke Skywalker yeah I mean
he's amazing he's so cool I guess all
odds still fights I love that I mean
handsome charismatic and cool yeah Luke
he defied everything no even he's just
like all of us we can relate this is
such a task that it's so enormous that
were like I don't know if I can again do
not there's no try and he did yeah and
if we're looking at the big picture then
I would definitely say Leia and ahsoka
uh you know yeah well like when I was
growing up you know I really just had
Leia and then there was you know that we
added Padme but now there's so many
female Star Wars characters what is it
like to be one of those characters that
girls are gonna cosplay as and look up
to it's really exciting and a little
scary at the same time but yeah like
Tom's been so fun to play and she really
has a like a cool kind of character to
her so I'm I'm hoping that people like
her the premiere up so we get a little
taste of her and she's got a lot of sass
so what is her dynamic with cast in the
show well he comes in and upsets the
apple cart because he's coming into
their like team fireballs kind of
dynamic and at first I think times kind
of put out because there's a lot of
things that she thought belonged to her
or you know like she was in charge of
that he kind of comes in and ruffles
those feathers so in the beginning it's
not so great like she sees him as a
threat
it becomes more sibling type of
relationship can you imagine what it's
like to be an ace pilot he's very naive
how are we gonna see him evolve
throughout the show uh he gets more not
you guys because it is one of those
things where it's like when the time
comes and you need to make a decision
and you need to make it fast you got to
stick by that decision that's what Cass
does is so he's going to he's going to
continue racing doing what he can to
become an ace pilot here
[Music]